What happens to a dream deferred?
It leads to bewildering frustration and corroding bitterness.
But somewhere I read of the freedom of assembly.
Somewhere I read of the freedom of speech.
Somewhere I read of the freedom of press.
Somewhere I read that the greatness of America is the right to protest for a right.
Free at last!
Thank God Almighty, we are free at last!
Deep rumblings that we hear today.
Rumbling of discontent is the thunder of disinherited masses,...
...rising from dungeons of oppression to the bright hills of freedom.
All over the world like a fever,...
...freedom is spreading in the widest liberation movement in history.
Martin Luther, stand up for righteousness!
Stand up for justice!
Stand up for truth!
And lo, I will be with you, even until the end of the world.
And I've seen the promised land.
I may not get there with you, but I want you to know tonight...
...that we as a people will get to the promised land.
I have a dream that one day...
...this nation will rise up and live out the true meaning of its creed:...
..."We hold these truths to be self-evident: that all men are created equal."